le service de midi est à peine terminée
l'équipe de christophe et enchaîne sur
les préparatifs pour le dîner des restos
du coeur
au menu est urgent fumée d'eau de biche
boeuf de kobe et caviar de soleil quand
on est chef étoilé on a aussi cette
envie de garder des sensations
inoubliables et je pense que
un caviar à la première fois qu'on en
mange c'est quelque chose qui reste à
vie et je suis vraiment fier de pouvoir
partager grâce à la famille en cas de
pouvoir partager tout ça avec avec ses
bénéficiaires
ces produits d'exception ont été données
par neuf producteurs locaux à famille
hennequart a notamment offert 1 kg de
caviar de sologne
tu as apporté les rillettes selon la
page tu as fait un bisou
sylvain arnould pêcheurs de loire à
fabriquer 80 petits pots de terrines de
silures pour l'occasion il me semble
important quand même de d'appuyer cette
démarche que christophe a quand même de
donner l'opportunité à des gens quand
même défavorisés de manger aussi des
produits fins et et voilà ils ont le
droit de aussi de partager des bonnes
choses comme tout le monde
18h toute la brigade de la maison d'à
côté déminage
mais bon on est parti à l'ego direction
la maison de quartier de blois viennent
dans la salle 80 bénéficiaires des
restos des bénévoles des gens de la rue
des personnes isolées
on a un petit boucher avec du caviar de
sologne à côté à côté c'est du boeuf
à l'excellent excellent c'est assez dur
de se dire voilà aujourd'hui je suis
bénéficiaire des restos du coeur
mais ça peut arriver à tout le monde en
fait on peut être manager on peut avoir
une situation et on peut tout perdre du
jour au lendemain et et voilà quoi il
faut pas avoir honte c'est un coup de
pouce que con à un moment donné d'un
accueilli et et heureusement que ya ce
jardin qui existent pour pouvoir qu'on
sent sans cesse que la vie de plus en
plus durs l'an dernier valérie était
assise à la table en tant que
bénéficiaire aujourd'hui elle travaille
pour christophe et à la plonge qu'il a
engagées après cinq ans de change
je commençais qomama désespérée même si
j'étais à la recherche d'emploi à partir
de 54 ans les portes se referment et là
christophe m'a tendu une
une bonne main et j'en suis très fier ce
dîner est bien plus qu'une soirée
festive c'est avant tout une aventure
humaine à laquelle de plus en plus
d'acteurs souhaitent participer